she's waited half her life for this
moment but for litt modèle Rosario the
last few hours seemed to take an
eternity finally the door to a new life
is opening a new life without a penis
yes I research for years that it's
really irreversible and I'm open about
it and and I'm very happy for that for
what will be perfectly because this made
through it and the truth will set free
me
Thailand is a popular port of call for
people who feel as if they were born
into the wrong biological sex
transgender people come here from all
over the world from Japan Russia the US
and Europe gender reassignment surgery
in Thailand costs around 2000 euros in
other countries it can run to over fifty
thousand there are no waiting lists here
and no awkward questions it's a cash
down procedure at your own risk
the operations however are generally
carried out by skilled doctors litmus
comes from the Philippines she's been
taking female hormones for 16 years and
already has breast implants now it's
time for the final cut my simple look
like I chained Japan to make a dress not
cut it out that chick it as much as
possible and take out something that is
useless and make a meal thing turning a
man into a woman here the procedure is
low-cost and fast but foreign
transgender tourists face regulations
even in Thailand Lacroix meets the
requirements she's over 18 has been in
counseling with at least two
psychologists and has undergone hormone
therapy and before the doctors will
operate every man to woman client also
has to spend time living as a woman at
age of 3 or 4 I find I'm different from
the other boys in my phone I find it
that I want Barbie not a gun
I wanna turn cosmetic not not a thing
that's a normal boy we play and at the
time I know it's something different
with me half male half female called
kotori's in Thailand transgender people
have an accepted place in society an
expression of Buddhist tolerance known
as the third gender cat eyes free Qin
the cosmetics sector or as models or
actors a mere achada made a name after
gender reassignment she now runs her own
beauty parlor in Bangkok selling fashion
and perfume ami often appears on TV and
in the tabloid press
I'll park mammal that my father came to
the hospital with me I was only 18 he
had to sign the paperwork and he had
tears in his eyes I had it all done in
one go top and bottom I'm really proud
of myself and what I've become
in Sweden got it Ami's found happiness
and recently a boyfriend as well he's
got short hair and his slender build
oh you haven't really thought about the
gender reassignment but I have had my
breasts removed and since then I feel a
lot more self-confident but mommy one
down we go in II was born a man now
she's a woman her boyfriend
born a woman who'd rather be a man a
little confusing but only at first it's
lit medel Rosario's big day she's
prepared for surgery and camel cosmetic
hospital in Bangkok litmus slept bad
light her mind was racing all night
never seen King about taken very
how is the pain yeah but I think that's
pretty normal being a baby for the
surgery
Littman enters the operating theater
operations like this our daily routine
for dr. Kamal and his colleagues along
with a few extras that might appeal to a
man wanting gender reassignment surgery
things like cheekbone sculpting nose and
shoulder reduction lip augmentation or
breast implants litt MERS operation
takes almost four hours it won't only
alter her body it'll change her whole
life then it's over God but that lady
she's got to recover now there were no
complications we're happy with the
result could for the first time in her
life lit my feels like everything's just
the way that it's supposed to be she'll
stay in Bangkok for two weeks of
post-operative care the incisions will
take three months to heal but a new
chapter of her life has begun my sister
Sumner stopped here and also my husband
greet me happy birthday because they
think that'd be his menuing birthday I
ever saw I was a like a butterfly
metamorphosis lit more has ambitious
plans she wants to work as a model to
study and find a good job but her
biggest wish is that people will accept
her just as she is as a human being